hey guys Ryan right here there's a lot
of hope videos apparently the Hulk and
Wolverine we're gonna check out the Alex
Luthor trailer the epic trailer for Hulk
vs. Wolverine epic trailer
let me emphasize that what I'm about to
share with you is tremendously sensitive
those to me personally on the army
you're aware that we've got an infantry
weapons development program in ww2 they
initiated a subprogram for biotech force
enhancement banners work was very early
phase he was so sure of what he was on
tested it on himself and something was
very wrong
[ __ ]
are you here to kill me because that's
sometimes with engage the Beast the
Beast gets angry
got you goddamn head off
that's it
you just roll over show your belly go
[ __ ] yourself pretty boy
man Alex Luther I'm gonna give you a big
middle [ __ ] finger dude I'm gonna
give you the one with the balls - I am
so mad at you
you keep making these awesome fan-made
trailers that looks so good
and it makes me wish it was real it
pisses me off that it's not so [ __ ] you
but thank you at the same time I like
how you were able to take footage from
x-men origins Wolverine a lot of it and
x-men The Last Stand two of the
shittiest x-men movies actually make you
look like something cool in this trailer
but no man the editing was great again
dude as a personal thing out of all the
movies that I've wanted to see from like
vs. stuff I have always wanted to see a
Hulk vs. Wolverine story I mean it's
something that we've all been drawn to
if you're into comic books okay I'm
about to give one of my dreams away
right here I personally want to like
make a whole versus Wolverine movie one
day and what I want to do hopefully no
one steals this is why I'm saying this
in front of thousands of people right
now I want to actually take the Hulk and
cast like a ten-foot actor in it like
that dude from The Longest Yard when he
becomes the Hulk and put it on practical
effects I'd want it to be all rated I'd
want it to be violent because you got
Wolverine with the claws and you got the
Hulk who's just this incredible
thrashing angry being and Wolverines got
a temper too you got a movie here that
could really deliver on awesome [ __ ]
violence and bloodshed and it could be
[ __ ] brutal so I would love to see
that happen Hollywood make it happen you
listening Hollywood do it anyway um
thanks Alex we're uploading that and
thank you fans for mentioning that was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
I want to start posting pictures of kids
with guns I really think more kids
should be armed with weapons these days
specifically shotguns assault rifles
maybe even a bazoo
so if you guys can just follow us there
so I can get product placement from gun
companies that'd be great cuz I really
think we should have a charity of guns
to get two little kids just my belief